Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Yesterday I interviewed
Christopher Key, who for a long time has said
he drinks and injects urine to for health and
something about the COVID vaccine. The interview
was completely off the wall insanity many of you
I don't know that we've gotten this many
emails and comments and voicemails about
any interview for a very, very long time.
Here is just one such voicemail I received.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, I was just listening to
your most recent episode with Christopher Key. Oh,
my God, that guy's a nutball. Yeah, I think
he drank too much of his own urine. And you're
going to be the brain surgeon. And this dude's
a Christian, and he's an embarrassing example
of one. I'm a Christian, and he just makes
us all look silly along with a whole bunch
of chompers. Anyways, thanks for all you do.
Speaker 1: All right. I want to say one particular
thing about the Christopher Key interview. A
number of people wrote to me and said, David,
why did you have this guy on? Why did you do this?
Some people said it wasn't worth my time. Others
said it was sort of mean because he's clearly
out of his mind or just incapable of carrying
on a conversation. I want people to understand
he demanded to be on because we talked about
him on the show and that seemed fair. And I'll
remind you, we have covered COVID disinformation
for years, and the COVID disinformation has
come from Michael Flynn. It's come from Trump,
it's come from Sherri Tenpenny. And we've covered
the COVID disinformation that was being spread by
Christopher Key. He saw our coverage. Wrote to me
and said, Have me on so I can tell you why you're
wrong about all this stuff you're saying.
It seems as though if I spoke about someone
and they say I want to defend myself, that I
should grant them that possibility. So we didn't
go out looking to interview Christopher Key.
It's obvious that, you know, the wheel might
be spinning, but the hamsters dead or whatever
other analogy or metaphor you want to use. But
he has to be on. And I had spoken about them,
so that's why why we accommodated it. Please
understand that we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today. There is some really sad stuff going on
with Senator Dianne Feinstein, which we're going
to discuss and it's not fun. But it's we need to
talk about it. Florida has rejected some Holocaust
textbooks for being too woke. A Florida teacher
says she's under investigation for showing the
class a Disney movie that has a gay character in
it. All of those stories will be on today's bonus
show. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and
get instant access to the bonus show o.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you want
to make money, right? Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Please help us make money on the bonus
show. And if you've been saying to yourself,
you know, maybe I'll get myself
one of those memberships someday
once the price is low enough. Monday, Memorial
Day, we're doing a one day membership special.
It's going to be out of this world. Be notified
of that by getting on my newsletter at David
Packman dot com. We'll see everyone on the
bonus show or otherwise. See you tomorrow.